I had a mother who when I was born
she had just, you know, escaped from undescribable trauma,
lived in the face of death and the dying.
It's unimaginable, what she was really exposed to.
I'm sure, in her books and in her writings and in her lectures,
she's not, I don't think she's even scraped the surface,
or dared to scrape the surface,
or been able to scrape the surface
of what she really had to endure.
Well, when I was younger, when I was a child,
she taught me how to spin the wool.
This fresh wool from farmers in like, Scotland or something.
We would sit together in the living room,
and she'd teach me how to, like, clean the wool and prepare it
and spin it, and then show me stuff she was making with it.
She made, like, cardigans.
I think she made a cardigan for me at some point
that I had when I was little.
Because I still knit and crochet and stuff all the time,
and I always think of her when I do that.
We know psychologically that if you allow that degree of trauma
to go under the– you know, to penetrate,
you die, you don't survive.
And so in some way you have to protect– you have to lock it out.
I'm a psychologist, and I work with these– It's not surprising
that I work with these kind of things myself.
It's interesting, I can't remember the statistic,
75 or 80% of second generation survivors
work in the health services as psychologists or doctors or therapists,
you know, and why is that? It's interesting, isn't it?
And that's been my salvation really,
understanding it myself as a phenomenon,
and this enabled me to a large extent,
to in a way, heal.
Heal, yeah.
I read some parts of the first book, but for me, honestly,
the way the transgenerational trauma works for me is
I get quite uncomfortable reading about
anything that has to do with war in general.
It's like I get a trauma response that it's not from my own life,
in response to any sort of stories about things like that,
or her story, like, I can't physically process it.
All the survivor wants to do is to protect their kids,
of course, but you can't do that.
You know, you think you can do that,
but you can't do that.
And they do it either by becoming extremely devout,
loyal to the Jewish faith, or rejecting it completely,
pretending it wasn't there,
and kind of that's what my mother did
for a large part of her life.
When I get into this, it moves–
my feelings get very sort of,
it opens up something very powerful in me,
because it's been such an emotionally powerful journey.
She thought she'd protected me.
She thought that I was free, that it hasn't been transferred,
you know? But it's really been a huge
piece of work for me for 20 years or so, and is continuing in a way.
She talked about it later in her life, obviously, about
what she'd been through when she wrote her books and everything.
But she was very emotionally detached from it,
which I think is something she had to do to cope with the trauma, obviously.
I can't imagine.
So I never talked to her personally about it.
When you grew up as a young child or as a baby
with someone that has just, in a way, escaped or
come out of multiple traumas over several years,
you're going to be living with someone who
has very explicit post traumatic stress symptoms,
which you know at that time nobody knew anything about it,
but it means you know emotional distance,
not being in contact with your feelings,
not being able to have empathy,
not because you're not empathetic,
but because, you know, your traumas are so severe
that you have enough surviving and managing from day to day.
and you put a lid on your emotions to be able to survive from day to day.
And you just imagine everything we know today
about child development, the important emotional presence,
the importance of emotional presence,
what that will do to that child, in terms of feeling, you know,
not seen or understood, or feeling lonely or fearful.
There's something very dangerous out there.
You know, there's nowhere to go.
There's no haven, there's no safe haven, secure base.
There's a French poet, Paul Celan.
He wrote, he was a Holocaust survivor himself.
And he talked about, he intuitively understood these things
when he wrote a poem called Black Milk.
Black breast milk and it passes something on
but what is passed on, the child has nothing to hang it on to.
There's no hooks to hang there to understand it.
But I'm very, very fortunate that being able to
use my life to understand these things and help other people.
I bear no resentment, no bitterness, no–
just, I feel just love, and I did for the last few years with my mother.
But it could easily be- I've experienced many of my clients
who are very glad when their parents die.
They just have never felt understood or met.
Because our parents, they can never understand us,
because, if they understand us, they have to understand themselves
and open up the spaces within themselves
which are just so threatening to access.
You can't go there, and that's very understandable,
Very understandable.
But these books and everything she wrote was all part and parcel.
This need to show that she was worth,
worthy of being in the world.
Having to prove her worth all the time in one way or another.
And that was a very strong driving force for her.
Because you're the evidence of the fact that life goes on,
that the Nazis didn't succeed, right?
I'm the evidence.
And I have to shine and go out there.
That's the that's the absolute message you're getting
as a child of a second generation.
You get out there and shine and show the world
that Hitler didn't succeed.
What gives me meaning and a feeling of relevance
is to be there for others. And I don't mean that that wasn't–
that was also so for my mother, but as a therapist, I am really using
this knowledge that I'm sharing in therapy room,
and I really can see and witness the extent to which this really
can support and help people understand themselves
and heal themselves, because it gives me a perspective very,
very few people have on life, and I'm very, very grateful for that.
Because it's so rewarding to be allowed to do that.
She's very– she was very brave.
She's like she's the most powerful woman I think I ever met in my life,
because she went through so much, and she persisted through it,
and she pushed even farther and achieved so many things.
To me, she's just like a symbol of like:
Don't give up, just keep pushing forward and do your best.
And she went far. She got places.
That's the only way I can sum it up, I think.
So maybe that's the point of my life.
Maybe that's why I am who I am, doing what I do.
Is that I'm going to somehow or another
– without having too big ideas about myself –
you know, I'm in a position to be able to try to,
in a way, resolve, to a certain extent, family traumas.
But to be able to embrace your life
and honour your life whilst you're still alive.
I think that's such an important thing to be able to do,
for better or for worse.
And forgive yourself, yeah.
It takes a lot of courage to take on, you know,
the consequences of your actions.
For better or for worse, you know?
And, yeah, you know, she's taught me a lot
and I'm deeply grateful for this.
I'm deeply grateful for having had the mother I had,
and having to have her work through these things,
because when I– my whole ability and capacity
as a therapist is dependent on that understanding
that I've been forced to embrace.
Which is incredibly challenging to acquire.
I think it's quite phenomenal what I've achieved, because
I could have taken my own life when I was 45, round about there.
I could have just ended it all, because
the whole thing seemed so insurmountable.
Since I was little, since I was born,
I've been a very strong willed person.
And I think that definitely comes from her,
because we were very similar in many ways.
Also very different in very many other ways.
But the thing that I saw in her, a lot, that I also saw in myself,
was that it's almost like stubbornness, but it's in a good way.
It's like, instead of being stubborn and annoying,
it's more just like, stubborn in the way that I refuse to give up
on things, like I refuse to just fall down and then give up.
Because I've been through a lot of ups and downs in my life,
and there's many points that if I wasn't the strong willed person that I am,
I would have given up and I wouldn't be here.
And I think that's really something that she gave to me.
My main focus of attention right now is my own death.
I'm working with embracing my own mortality and–
but just to be able to embrace death as something
that I can embrace with gratitude, as a natural
and normal conclusion of a life that's lived to the full.
Which is what I would have wished for my mother.
So maybe, if I can do that, I can somehow, in a way, heal her.
Yeah, in a way, within me. We carry our parents within us.
You know, certainly.